here to explain all that Evolution Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jared Fox News
contributor Jason chaitz and the host of
Tommy larren is fearless on outkick
Tommy lren is with us how do we start
with you know all the times Joe Biden
said I never once discussed uh the
foreign business deals with my son my
brother or anybody else for that matter
how did we start there how did it then
become the president was never in
business with his son how did it evolve
even further my father was not
financially involved in the business you
know can you explain the the
evolution uh because I think I have a
pretty good handle on a Greg Jarrett and
that is that with each new piece of
information that the house oversight
committee or Judiciary Committee or Ways
and Means Committee came up with they
had to come out with an excuse to
explain away the previous lie is that a
good theory on my
part sure absolutely and you know Joe
Biden continues to double down on his
lies and nearly 70% of Americans don't
believe it they think he either
committed uh actions that are illegal or
unethical so you know Americans have
wised up to Joe Biden's lies and the
allegations against him you know Sean
there's serious and credible there's
compelling evidence of impeachable
conduct he actively aided and eded
corrupt schemes operated by his son
netting tens of millions of dollars from
foreign interest while selling access
and Promises of influence there's
documents and testimonies that implicate
the father as complicit and so you know
exploiting a public office to enrich
your family even if you don't profit
yourself that's both a criminal offense
Sean and it's an impeachable one well
Tommy let's get your take on this I mean
to me it's a slam dunk case uh but if
you listen to the media mob if you
listen to the Democratic party
uh they just don't seem to care very
much do
they they don't seem to care but I
believe that they actually do care
they're just hoping that the American
people won't catch on because up until
now the American voter hasn't seemingly
really cared about this corruption the
bribery scheme but it's up to House
Republicans it's up to Republicans in
general to hammer this point home
Republicans cannot sit on the fence on
this issue on the impeachment inquiry on
questioning Hunter Biden holding him in
contempt Republicans have to go hard
harder than ever because they have to
set a precedent for too long Republicans
have slow walked this they didn't be
want to be the ones that held firm on
their word didn't want to go after
Hillary Clinton have kind of soft pedal
their their pursuit of Joe and Hunter
Biden they have to go hard this is their
opportunity set a precedent show the
American people that you have a backbone
in a spine and end this once and for all
you've got the evidence now's time to
hit this one home I believe they can do
it but to all the spineless Republicans
that don't want to enter this fight now
is the time to fight grow some fangs and
get ready to go to war here you know
Jason you've been involved in
investigations like this in the past and
your years in Congress uh what is your
take as you stand back and you look at
all the evidence and everything all
three of the Committees have been able
to find what is your take and how far do
you think this goes because I really
believe with the Republicans yesterday
going forward with the impeachment
inquiry that this now is a very SE a
serious and clear and present danger to
Joe Biden's
presidency I I totally agree with you
Sean I think it's also an indictment on
the Department of Justice I think part
of the reason that the media covered it
up and didn't cover it is that they knew
attorney general Garland and his uh
henchmen there uh were not going to
charge him if not for that judge who
stepped up and kind of broke apart this
plea deal all of this was going to be
pushed aside and as as chairman uh uh
Jim Jordan has highlighted you know why
did they let the statutes of limitations
expire this is all the Department of
Justice is doing they knew that they
were going to go ahead and let this guy
off and Joe Biden could just wash his
hands of it and move on so yeah the
charges are serious because you have a
president of the United States who is
potentially compromised by our very
adversaries such as China and we got to
get to the bottom of it Department of
Justice isn't going to do it Republicans
in the house have to do it Jason what
does it mean why is this inquiry so
important this vote yesterday so
important especially in terms of all the
stonewalling that has been going
on look Congress should be able to go
ahead and issue a subpoena and have that
enforced but if you're going to go to
the courts to force the extraction of
documents compel the attendance of the
witnesses it is stronger to have a full
vote of the house to have that
impeachment inquiry it is totally a
legal strategy because it will probably
end up in the courts and the courts have
got to back you up in order to do it
that vote made it that much stronger
Greg do you agree with
that yeah I absolutely do and I can't
overstate how utterly idiotic it was for
Hunter Biden to hold a press conference
to bracingly defy valid subpoena to
appear for his deposition which is
routine and instead demand his own
conditions that it be a public hearing
he has no right under law to do that
what don't get to dictate terms failure
to comply is a crime so legally hter
made the case against himself and
politically I think it backfired fueling
the need for the House vote but even
worse if Joe Biden conferred with his
son as the White House Suess and
encouraged him to commit a crime by
defying The subpoena well that's another
basis for impeachment it's called Sean
obstruction you know Tommy I look at
this and uh I know you've worked very
hard in your career as Greg has as Jason
has as we all have um wouldn't you like
a gig where if your dad was president
and you had no experience at all that
you'd make millions and millions of
dollars um why I'm I'm trying to
understand the lack of curiosity on the
part of the media mob and the left in
this country how is it possible that
somebody with no experience can make all
of that money that can take specific
actions that ensures that you continue
to get paid again with no experience and
it doesn't seem to raise an eyebrow uh
in the minds or of liberals to them it's
like an everyday Affair is this is that
the ordinary way that people do business
that maybe I not learned
yet well I'll tell you this Sean I I
have never had my father sit on any of
my business calls or my personal calls
or any calls but I'm not sure that my
dad has the you know the power of a vice
president or a sitting president so
maybe that's where it's different but
you just saw earlier today the ladies
and I use the word ladies very Loosely
of the view coming to Joe and Hunter's
cover once again passing this off as a
Father's love saying that other people
pointing the finger at Megan McCain by
the way pointing the finger at her as if
she has done the same thing which is
obviously false a lie and erroneous but
they will continue to do this in the
media make it seem like this is just how
Washington works that's why it's up to
Republic to show that this is not how
Washington works this will not be
acceptable and they have to go hard and
take this thing through to the end to
show the American people that
Republicans are serious about this and
these people will be brought to Justice
doj be damned Biden White House be
damned this has got to go forward and it
has to go all the way to the end Greg
legal question on what Tommy just
brought up and that has to do with Megan
McCain she said she will consult with
the lawyers we know about times V
Sullivan she is a public figure do you
think she may have a case against the
view well from what I saw of the right
up to the clips they didn't mention her
by name I suppose the implication was
there or Megan McCain certainly
construed that way but she is a public
figure uh opinion is sometimes but not
always protected speech uh so be a tough
case for her to bring I predict she
won't bring such a case all right well
we'll see over time appreciate appreci
it thank you all hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else